foreign
Lee is with us in St Louis hi Lee
welcome to the Ramsey Show
Mr Ramsey I was calling today because
I'm trying to get through these baby
steps kind of on my own since my husband
and I our finances are separated and I'm
wondering if I should stop putting into
my 401k to get there faster
why are your finances is it Leah or Lee
it's Leah that's okay no no it's great
it's great I've been called worse oh my
gosh uh I'll call you by right now
though
um yeah Leah why why are the finances
separate
they didn't start off that way uh we've
been married for 14 years in August
and when we started out our finances
were together
but we fought a lot about money bills
were always paid I'll say that I've
always worked full-time but my husband
when we got married was going to school
and he actually went to pharmacy school
and when he finished pharmacy school
and started getting what I call like his
big money
we were doubling up on his loans and
paying those off faster
but the checking account was always to
zero and that he just couldn't take it
anymore and I couldn't take the fighting
so we decided together to split our
finances
but now fast forward that's been about
eight years and I'm still kind of
living paycheck to paycheck essentially
and I know that that bothers him for me
to say that but that's well it's kind of
a Dr Phil moment how's that working for
you it's not
it's not I know so Leah here's the truth
here's what we have found it's really
difficult
it's not that it's absolutely impossible
but I'm gonna say it is really difficult
to win with money long term and have
money goals like getting out of debt
saving up an emergency fund like doing
all the baby steps that we talk about
when you are in a household and you're
working on one income and the other
person is there with their income but
you guys share bills your names are
maybe on each other's debt because
you're married like I mean it's like
it's half it's half in it's half out and
so for one to go on this really straight
path and run really hard while the other
one isn't there it's almost like you're
just dragging this weight behind you
trying to make progress and it's really
difficult almost impossible to make
progress when that happens and so
honestly I would say Leah I mean the
Tactical answer to your question is yes
pause retirement while you're paying off
debt and getting an emergency fund in
place but that's
um that that's that's two three steps
later I think the first main step is you
and your husband I mean honest sitting
down and you guys really getting to this
point though where you
communicate obviously your needs your
desires what your fears were but the
frustration was eight years ago and
bring it back up because what y'all
basically did was just decided to avoid
a fight instead of get to a resolution
by just separating a lot of couples do
that well we just five we can't do this
so we're gonna just separate and just
ignore each other financially and run on
these two separate roads but the issues
are still there and they're probably
coming up in other places in your
marriage too Leah
yeah he we we still fuss and fight about
it because he's unbelievably Frugal like
he goes neutral down a hill to save on
gas so he's paid off his student loans
which were very high like over 160 000
he's paid those off he has an amazing
savings
but I'm still over here like chugging
along paycheck and why is that because
of your income or is that because of
your money habits
I definitely a combination he makes
double what I make
um but we try to split the bills so I
feel like okay I can get the bills met
but then I've discovered now through
your book think I'm so excited you're on
the show today because I love you and
and reading your book has opened my eyes
to my own issues that I didn't even know
I had and I was like oh my gosh that's
me that's that's why I do that and I
didn't understand so now I'm like
you know this Age of Enlightenment and
I'm like oh okay so now I'm like okay
let's make a budget and let's not spend
money on Amazon and let's not go out to
eat five times a week and you know so
I'm learning yeah um there's definitely
some Behavior stuff on my side but also
when I'm still trying to meet like all
the bills that we've kind of said that
we would meet together but separate it's
hard yeah yeah so the this overall
situation is not efficient
it's not good relationally
you're not resolving the underlying
issues he's not respecting your ability
to enjoy life and he's gone on with his
frugality so much that instead of it
being a virtue it's turned into
something you're starting to resent
uh you're paying more than half the
bills with less than half the income I'm
not sure how you figured that out was
okay
um and so uh you know there's just so
much wrong with this so the old book of
common prayer says this
for richer for poor and sickness and
health unto thee all my worldly Goods I
pledge
and it's this idea of joining our lives
because here's what happens relationally
and practically as well
you what you spend your money on says
what you value
and you value going out to eat and
enjoying life like Rachel
okay Rachel's mom on the other hand has
six-year-old leftovers in the freezer
she's your husband okay
they fell out when I opened the door the
other day and I said you're throwing
some of this out or I am it hit me on
the toe this has got to stop and so this
is this is how life works right I mean
this is marriage and so we're going to
I'm going to enjoy my wife's frugality
she's going to know that her life is
much more fun because I'm around because
I'm the minister of fun at our place and
I'm the spender by Nature even though I
teach this stuff every day and so um
I'll be the one that plans the fancy
fancy trip that she gets to take so
you're that person and that's he has
that benefit by having you but he's not
getting the benefit of that you have the
benefit of having some net worth and
actual Nest Egg built because he's
freaking Frugal that's awesomeness
see Larry Burkett used to say if two
people like just to like get married one
of you is unnecessary
but you're not getting the benefit the
complimentary of your complementary
skills and values instead they became a
reason for separation and Leah I'm
telling you too there's a level of
couples when you separate your finances
you're separating something that's
supposed to be unified yeah dreams when
you marry someone you are sharing your
life not in this like codependent way of
you know all that like you still are
Leah and he is still him and that's that
was to Dave's Point earlier like you're
still going to be who you are but when
you separate that and you guys don't
work together with your finances I'm
telling you there is stuff that you guys
are avoiding and you end up being
roommates that there's a level of
intimacy that is created and
vulnerability when you say I I
everything I have is yours everything
you have is mine and we're a team we're
married like it should be us against the
world and instead you're in this like
triangle with the world trying to dance
around it and it's exhausting so your
marriage will be Thrive will be so much
richer and deeper if you guys work on
the same team so that's the next
conversation we're going to give you a
financial Pace University I want the two
of you together to go through it I'm
gonna give it to you as a gift if that
doesn't solve it get in marriage
counseling for the good of your
relationship and your future